hi my name is tyler malek i'm the head
ice cream maker at salt and straw and
today we're going to make a salted
malted chocolate chip cookie dough ice
cream the base of this ice cream is a
molasses vanilla ice cream and then
there's two mixens here one is a malted
chocolate chip cookie dough and then the
second is a homemade chocolate fudge
with this flavor we wanted to basically
take something that was like super
nostalgic and classic and put a little
bit of a twist on it to make our cookie
dough food safe we actually pre-bake the
flour the malt powder it's an extract of
basically the same malts that they'd use
in a beer you'll often taste similar
profiles maybe in a malted milkshake
kind of like evolves that cookie dough
and gives it this really nice nutty
flavoring profile
when i was growing up i loved cooking
and the beauty of ice cream is that not
only can we bring people together but
more than that is that we can be so
creative with it with this flavor it's
cool because it's just you know
approachable enough that it really like
tugs on some of that nostalgia so for me
it's like walking and up here on oregon
coast eating you know a scoop and it's
just like it's cheap it's delicious
there's nothing like it
i love using xanthan gum it's terrifying
because it starts with an x and so a lot
of people think it's you know a scary
ingredient but actually it's not it's
going to maintain the quality for up to
a month most at-home ice creams if
you're not using a gum like that will
only last maybe two or three days
ice cream is just naturally intimidating
and it shouldn't be when you look at its
core we're melting a little bit of sugar
into milk adding some cream and letting
that sit overnight and that's an ice
cream base and that's all you need in
this case we added a little bit of
molasses and vanilla in other cases you
could add a little bit of strawberries
or a little bit of cocoa powder make a
chocolate there's so many different
avenues you can take with this this is
not a complicated process and actually
like hurts my soul to go to like a
goodwill and see how many you know ice
cream machines are out on the shelf it's
gonna turn out incredible there's
nothing like fresh homemade ice cream
the crazy thing is coming straight out
of the machine there's science that can
back this up that is the best the ice
cream will ever be
eating that whole thing right then and
there is actually like i i praise you
for being able to do that
man it's really incredible to be able to
make ice cream every day my favorite
part is being able to constantly go out
and source new products and new stories
to tell through our ice cream there's
something magical about that i think
so we'll put maybe a half inch layer of
ice cream and then drizzle in the fudge
and then another half inch layer of ice
cream drizzle fudge over that and by the
time it freezes it'll scoop just really
beautifully and get these nice thick
distinct ribbons coming through
when i'm making ice cream depending on
what stories we want to tell or what
parts of nostalgia that we want to tug
on we can kind of use our ice cream
almost as a platform that's why i think
it's fun to put such a unique twist on
it it's not going to be like what you've
ever tasted but it might kind of just
barely touch on that
this flavor is especially fun when it
comes to eating it just like that
satisfaction you're going to have like a
ton of texture in that cookie dough the
fudge is going to be a little sticky but
also kind of just give you this really
deep punch of chocolate flavor and the
ice cream itself that's the star of the
show and that's what we want to show off
at the end of the day so the ice cream
should have this perfect kind of velvet
texture in your mouth
that's a magical experience and i think
something that hopefully everyone gets
to try out and have fun with
i've fallen in love with making it
oh yes
oh
[Music]